last one and I promise it's the most fun
okay no cardboard in volume jurors
circle for me okay sorry I should've
told you to do the compass but if you
just draw a small one there you'll see
my doing pre terrible in a second anyway
here's my circle it's pretty good now
I've done better okay now he's really
good doing my circle the circle clearly
doesn't want to play this game he
doesn't want to get don't break him up
into like triangles or whatever don't
put extra boxes around you can't no
matter which way you do it you're gonna
get 30 bits yeah and that's why when we
were doing perimeter worth of
circumference we had a special formula
for the young area of a circle right so
he played a different game except we can
make the circle play a game he's the way
I'm gonna do it okay now I'm just gonna
show this to you if you like look at it
at the one when I'm finishing your life
okay just let the nd settle in your mind
here's what I want you to try to imagine
this is a second scenario right I want
you to think of this area like a whole
bunch of lines added up together kind of
like if you had a whole bunch of roofs
right well maybe just one verb and it
was coiled around around the rounded
like a reasonable statement like that
and when you put it all the way what you
have is a circle okay so I want you to
just imagine that can think of a circle
what I think is what I'm then gonna do I
want you to imagine if I then take the
circle and I cut it along here okay a
longer radius
okay that's from the center to the edge
to the circumference okay
and what will happen is all my ropes
they'll all come apart yeah they're all
just sort of fall into pieces okay and
I'm going to have a whole bunch of
individual little ones whole bunch of
rows now Ketones not a trick question
but has a weeding son how long is the
shortest room how long is the shorts
worth it's like it's like it has lured
lengths like it's right there in the
middle right there's nothing's anything
okay what about the longest word right
what was the length of the longest route
it'll be the whole thing around if you
agree with that but we know how long the
circumference is right what's the
formula for circumference it's 2 pi oh
yeah okay so what I've got is my I've
got my shortest right I'm gonna put my
longest wrote over here you already told
me how long it is okay now what's the
relationship between the longest rope
and the shortest road and all these
ropes in between well they're just gonna
get shorter and shorter and shorter
until you get to that one that we
started moving right so the shape I'm
going to yes it's gonna look something
like this do you agree work with me here
okay so if you can see like the my
drawing might not be very good but the
principle is down that as you go from
the inside probably the inside to the
outside
you get progressively longer ropes do
you agree until you get to the longest
one which is hollowing it how long is it
again it's two pi oh hold on
which way did I cut this which way I cut
it I cut it along the radius right yeah
right yeah so this thing here is a
triangle but you know what the area of a
triangle is right don't you the area of
a triangle is 1/2 times the base what's
the base of this triangle times the
height what's the height of this
triangle yeah cancel I there are other
ways to work out exactly that's right I
guess so I promised you six formulas I
gave you six these last two that I've
done the trapezium and the circle I'll
show you right now
yeah the last two here's the formula
sheet here's page one you scroll Scroll
scroll his page two and right there on
the left hand side you can see area of a
circle there's one and then down kiya
area of a trapezium so those are the
hottest ones like you saw as we
explained them the first moment like oh
yeah
a my bangs simple the loss - we had to
kind of play some tricks and they're
caught morning work with electronic okay
which is why it being that they
qualitatively harder they give these
okay